okay here we are on YouTube Tom how do
you keep ticket prices to your shows
affordable by insisting I mean the
that's it that's I mean if well also by
being popular because enough people come
out so even if people do come out but I
mean the first the first three shows of
this tour that we played so far was a
twenty dollar ticket we gave all of it
away it's insisting on right on point of
view and the way that you want to do
your business which is different from
other acts you know but it's not cheap
to put on a rock show it's not it's not
you have to absorb some of that cost and
you make that part of the thing that
you're doing and there's good points and
bad points between music and comedy but
all my music friends are so jealous that
I just show up yeah as long as the mic
works yeah yeah that's true that's true
sound check that's true that's like when
singers when you when you do do a show
for a $20 ticket right sure a lot of you
I mean you can't do anything without
lots of equipment and electricity and
people in government but I mean that's
it's a curse in a way like that yeah how
we're gonna do some ourselves oh how
hella worth it is it smart of Hillary
Clinton to engage with Donald Trump on
Twitter good question
I say yes that's where the audience is
same way reason why Obama goes on well
every show but this as we know lots of
you know like lots of dumb ass shows
because you know you got to go where the
audience is they're not watching Meet
the Press how long do you think they
were holding that delete your account
tweet yes like that was like felt like
that had the feel of something they had
a turf dust off the top shelf
you know and how many days before that
did Hillary just learn what that meant
oh right yeah hey Bernie
hey Bernie would you like to read the
next question for Andrew do you think
Hillary Clinton will be tough
when we tough enough on Wall Street this
is my new career as a liquid right
that's not that harder Bendel leave the
Hillary Clinton let me cover the hood
Wall Street telephone elfies it's
relative it's Ridge not tough compared
to what Bernie would do and not tough
compared to Elizabeth Warren I'll do she
she's gonna be pushed to some degree but
I don't think he's gonna be pushed
nearly to the degree that I think
probably a lot of people even in this
room wanted to be do you think it
mattered those speeches she made to Wall
Street that Bernie was always railing
about released the transcripts of those
pictures if I don't the speeches
mattered in that she said something I
don't either
then why don't you release it no but I
will say this the relationship that she
has to corporate America writ large
forget about just Wall Street right you
know when people make comments about the
foundation and you know what Bill
Clinton was doing what she's doing in
the speeches and the money and all of
that's not good that's not good and
ultimately that colors the route that
colors everything it just does it's a
Wall Street candidate she's a centrist
Democrat they're Wall Street Canada yes
that's the gig I think the thing about
those speeches is probably why she
didn't release them is because there's
probably so anodyne and boring so they
were paying her a lot of money to say
nothing and that's actually it's kind of
a scam you know that shows how much in
her in her in her hat wide deep the
relationship is that weird isn't she
saying a lot of really nice things yeah
about people that are reviled but did by
Lana there's only one thing she thought
of Wall Street is yeah does anyone think
she's not and she's not gonna walk back
from these things I dissipate she will
release this washout nominee and now
that it's over and again to not to beat
the dead horse about what I was saying
at the end of this show and last show
but capitalism is not the enemy just
unchecked capitalism right right hi
I mean Cathy has brought more wealth and
higher standards of living to more
people if you're working an Indonesian
sweatshop might have a different opinion
of that hold on um you could you
couldn't be charging $20 to those
tickets if you if you had not been as
successful as you have been or we don't
we don't we don't live in an
anarcho-syndicalist utopia when we do
I'll be in a band in that one too this
is where I mean they they sell noam
chomsky books at Barnes & Noble you
don't mean like that's that's that's
where we are as I'm trying to I'm
working hard to change that you know but
Hillary Clinton is not yeah wait wait I
don't know what you said I can pretend I
knew what does that mean they sell burnt
no no I mean I mean I think the argument
that was being made that a successful
rock and roll musician has benefited
from capitalism therefore I should not
criticize it no no I'm you shouldn't
criticize it just that you have that
again like democracy the worst system
except for all the others and that it
does bring my analogies always it's a
raging river but it's you got to have
the river flow in the way it naturally
flows not like the Communist Chinese are
trying to make the river run backwards
you know but you just put dams and locks
on the river so that it doesn't kill
people River isn't is a river is a
natural phenomenon capitalism is a
morally bereft system you know that
harms much of the planet Oh hold on hold
on agrees there's nothing more natural
there was things to pay for what
solution people been paying people for
other things that right there was time
to trade and selfishness there is
nothing more natural baby builder in
America do start Mary
has taken more people out of poverty
around the world than any other city
already - that's right that's true yes
it's completely not even a relative
unlocker unless you're making Nike shoes
in an Indonesian sweatshop ok which is a
which is a crucial part of what
capitalism is like you cannot have you
cannot have Rodeo Drive without that
sweatshop you can't write ok yeah but we
but well I'm not sure that the case i
think would win people out with that
shopper doing way better right and also
know it assumes it'll be grotesque
economic inequality on the planet that's
right zooms and it's predicated on
grotesque economic in quite the way the
sweatshop that they work in probably is
the better job they went to that sweat
job because they had a work job and an
atom's also in the last 30 years we've
lifted something like 2 billion people
that I've covered Harvard E and the
number of people in the like extreme
poverty level is that lowest ever okay
so you know I mean yeah I mean it's it's
true and that's why I said don't
romantic eyes either system you need
both every modern economy is a mix of
capitalism socials we've been to have
quasi socialist for hundred years it's
not a bad word and Bernice one of the
people who more than anybody helped make
it not a bad word Katie do you think
there's any chance Romney will still be
drafted to run as the Republican nominee
no no absolutely Mon you know I mean I I
think the reality is that Mitt Romney
understands how difficult it is to win a
general election he's not gonna just go
out there to be a spoiler he'd only go
if he thought he could win I don't think
he believes he can win but he wants it
this is gonna be why she would run again
I'm not listening to you baby Bernie
he's gonna let Donald Trump own this
loss there's no doubt about it
okay all right well thank you very much
you're all very entertaining